J'espère que vous allez bien. Yes. Donc
aujourd'hui, on va parler de comment
Lemplacer.
Donc L va remplacer le toi qui travaille
dans ton entreprise. Donc c'est
l'objectif de cette vidéolà. Euh on fa
un plan c étapes pour faire la
transition avant que Li la fasse pour
toi. Donc sans plus tarder, on va
commencer directement.
Yes ! Donc je vais ter un peu ça ici.
Yes sir. Donc ton ton business arrête si
tu prends une semaine de vacances. Si
c'est ça vraiment ta réalité en ce
moment, tu as pas un business, tu as un
emploi très stressant. C'est la
différence. Si tu es un entrepreneur, ta
business doit rouler sans toi. Tu dois
pas travailler
sur tu dois pas travailler en dedans de
ta business. Tu dois pas être un employé
de ta business, tu comprends ? Tu dois
être l'entrepreneur derrière le CEO qui
va travailler sur la business, voir
l'entreprise
comme un actif, un actif qui doit rouler
qui doit rouler.
Donc euh
tu as un abonnement chat GPT, tu as vu
les 10 prompt pour être plus productif,
tu as automatisé tes courriels. C'est
peut-être ça en ce moment ta réalité
mais tout repose encore sur toi. Tu as
encore trop de tâches puis tes vraies
vacances, ben c'est impossible parce que
tu dois tout le temps penser à ta
business. Tes employés sont dépendants
de toi. Ils posent tout le temps des
questions euh sur quoi faire. C'est des
questions, c'est des problématiques,
whatever. tu es dépendant, ben
l'entreprise est dépendante de toi, donc
tu es pas vraiment libre puis ton
entreprise est pas encore un actif à 100
%.
Donc on va parler un peu du euh
du cadr du cash flow de Robert Kzaki. Là
écoute me cacher un peu
le euh
Robert Kaki, désolé. Donc du cash flow,
tu as un employé. Tu es un employé, tu
changes son temps contre un salaire. Euh
sécurité en échange de liberté. Donc tu
travailles x nombre d'heures, tu vas
avoir x nombre d'argent qui va rentrer.
Mais ton temps que tu travailles est
égal au à l'argent que tu vas recevoir.
Par la suite, travailleur indépendant.
Donc tu possèdes un emploi déguisé en
business. Donc arrêter de travailler
égal arrêter de gagner. Donc par
exemple, si tu es un travailleur
autonome qui fait je sais pas moi, tu es
un tu es un avocat écoute ou tu es un
comptable puis tu travailles dans une
entreprise donc tu as ton entreprise, tu
as ton cabinet de comptable par exemple
mais tu es le seul comptable ben si tu
arrê de travailler, tu as pas d'argent
qui rentre. Donc puis il y en a beaucoup
des entrepreneurs qui vont arrêter là,
qui vont être juste des travailleurs
indépendants, mais ils vont penser que
c'est des entrepreneurs, ils vont penser
qu'il ont une entreprise mais au final
sont juste salariés de leur entreprise,
sont juste propriétaire de l'entreprise
où c'est qui travaill mais tu travailles
tout le temps comme salarié guet.
Là par la suite tu propriétaire donc son
entreprise tourne même quand il dort.
Les systèmes travaillent pour lui. C'est
là que tu dois être. C'est là que
l'objectif que tu dois être c'est que
ton entreprise toutes les processus qui
roulent.
Tout est détaillé pour pas que ça
revienne vers toi
puis que ton entreprise soit vivante
puis agrandit. Même si toi tu es pas là.
tu travailles pas en dedans de ton
entreprise. Toi ton rôle ça va de
travailler sur l'entreprise. Donc de
comment la faire sk la comment comment
attaquer des nouveaux marchés comment tu
sais tu vas aller travailler sur
l'entreprise qui est vivante pour la
faire grandir. Ça être ça ton objectif.
Pu sinon par la suite investisseur ou
c'est que ton argent génère plus
d'argent l'argent travaille à sa place.
Donc même que là après ça, tu quittes
vraiment le tu es lui qui va faire
grandes entreprises, tu vas juste
investir dans les entreprises qui
roulent déjà puis tu vas être vraiment
euh un chair qui va pour qui va être là
pour aider mais qui va vraiment pas
travailler dans l'entreprise. Donc un
autre un autre niveau. Puis quand tu es
propriétaire, ben normalement quand tu
es tu as une entreprise, idéalement
c'est d'avoir uniquement une entreprise
pour que tu travailles sur l'entreprise.
don tout ton 100 % à travailler sur
l'entreprise pour l'améliorer. Alors
qu'investisseur, tu peux avoir plusieurs
entreprises dans lesquelles que pas tu
travailles mais tu es investis donc que
tu peux les aider. Donc plus tard quand
tu as plus de capital puis quand tu as
plus de connaissance là tu peux arriver
dans investisseur c'est là que c'est
ultra payant puis lucratif parce que tu
peux avoir cinq business qui roulent tu
es investisseur dedans, tes aides avec
ton réseau de contact, tes connaissances
puis tu investis dedans puis c'est là
que l'argent rentre puis c'est là que
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
multimillionnaires, milliardaires se
situent son investisseur parce qu'il ont
quitté la partie propriétaire de
l'entreprise. prise euh
donc la la distinction qui change tout.
Donc
travaille l'entreprise, tu es
l'entreprise donc tuexécutes les tâches
toi-même. Tout passe par toi, tu
travailles pour ton business, ton
horizon c'est cette semaine. Qu'est-ce
que je peux faire cette semaine pour que
ça roule ? Puis tu es remplaçable par
les a veux pas quand tu es trop axé sur
la tâche ou la gestion de tes de tes de
ton staff, tu es remplacé par l' parce
que l' peut reproduire des processus. Si
tu documentes tes processus, l' peut
faire les processus.
Donc c'est pour ça que je dis tu es
remplaçable par L
versus travailler sur l'entreprise. Donc
ton business travaille pour toi. Donc là
tu construis des systèmes qui roulent.
L'IA et les outils exécutent. Ton
business travaille pour ta vision. C'est
ce que tu vois. C'est où c'est que tu
t'en vas.
L'entreprise va travailler pour que tout
roule, que tout soit tous les processus
euh s'utoritader.
Ton horizon, ça va être 10 ans. Toi, tu
vas penser dans le futur ça va être quoi
les priorités ? C'est où les tu sais ça
ça ça va être où les les bottles neck
que l'entreprise va va rencontrer, les
nouvel tech, les enjeux
socioéconomiques. Tu vas être là, tu vas
penser à ça. Puis pour que l'entreprise
grandisse, il doit avoir quelqu'un qui
pense à ça. Parce que si tu es juste
accès aux semaines, une semaine,
ben
un momenté, c'est parce que tu vas te
faire dépasser par les nouvelles tech,
la les compétiteurs que eux ils pensent
au potentiel futur, aux opportunités
futures. Donc ceux par exemple qui sont
juste en tout temps à une semaine, une
semaine, une semaine, ils vont jamais
implanter l'A. Ils vont jamais implanter
l' parce que c'est trop loin. C'est trop
de temps pour
optimiser ça, c'est trop de temps pour
l'implanter. Euh puis on voit pas où
c'est que ça mène, tu sais. Alors que si
tu penses dans 10 ans, tu te dis OK,
c'est
illogique
de ne pas en ce moment là implanter dans
notre entreprise même au plus à la plus
petite échelle parce que dans 10 ans les
entreprises qui sont 100 %
c'est eux qui vont toutes renfler sur le
terrain. Donc l'important c'est
justement ça va être de travailler en ce
moment puis l'implanter au maximum de
petit à petit. écoute où c'est que on
est rendu le budget et cetera.
Investir en R2 pour voir les les les
nouvelles les nouvelles ressources, les
le potentiel, qu'est-ce qui peut être
optimisé pour que dans 10 ans, ben on
soit in, tu comprends ? Qu'on soit pas
out parce que on n pas optimisé à temp.
Avant de faire une torche, pour toi,
pose-toi cette question en tant
qu'entrepreneur. Est-ce que tu aimes ça
? Donc tu gardes la tâche parce qu'elle
te plaît, pas parce que elle crée de la
valeur. Donc la passion égale pas une
stratégie.
Ça ça dépend.
Euh
faire des tches que tu par exemple, je
prends l'exemple de
mort qui est entrepreneur à Dubaï et qui
disait que lui aimait ça faire des
landing page pour la stratégie, pour le
côté
artistique un peu que ce soit beau et
cetera ça lui aimait ça.
Mais stratégiquement
si dans ton entreprise il y a pas tout
qui roule encore ben va pas mettre 3 4h
5h peu importe une semaine entière à
travailler sur une landing page par
toi-même parce que là ton temps, il est
pas valorisé à sa juste valeur. C'est
qui qui peut le faire ben elle va le
faire tu comprends ? Mais la petite
variante que je veux ajouter, c'est que
si tu es rendu à un point où que ça
t'ajoute vraiment du bonheur à toi en en
tant qu'entrepreneur de faire cette
tâche là,
pour ma part, je dirais vos go, je veux
dire, je pense que ça peut avoir de la
valeur ajoutée. Donc intéressant de de
le faire par toi-même. Tu peux le faire
une fois de temps en temps ou vraiment
optimiser ce qui peut être optimisé puis
fais ce que tu aimes pour tu sais il
faut quand même avoir une petite des
petites choses qui sont cool que tu
aimes faire puis tu es bon à faire mais
c'est sûr qu'il faut penser valeur
ajoutée et levier donc mais c'est une
bonne question à se poser de est-ce que
tu le fais parce que tu aimes ça ou
parce que ça crée vraiment de la valeur
puis si ça crée pas de la valeur euh
remets ça en question mais c'est pas une
vérité absolue là mais c'est par la
suite. Bon, je suis perfectionniste, tu
veux que ça soit fait à ta façon, mais
est-ce que ça change vraiment le
résultat ?
Si tu es perfectionniste, c'est du du
fake work. Sincèrement, moi je l'ai vécu
aussi de travailler sur une landing
page, travailler sur un site internet,
travailler sur un logo, peu importe,
puis de passer full de temps là-dessus,
mais qu'au final euh tu pas tester le
marché et cetera ou que tu travailles
sur une tâche pour que ce soit beau puis
tout, mais au final ça pas tant de
valeur ajoutée puis ça pourrait être
fait par Li remet en question.
uniquement un cerveau humain peut faire
ça si c'est la vision relation clé
créativité stratégique décision critique
ça ça pour les prochaines années là ça
va valoir de l'or parce que un cerveau,
quelqu'un qui réfléchit vraiment puis
qui a une bonne vision des il comprend
il sait il y a des bonnes relations un
bon un bon réseau, il y a une bonne
créativité stratégique décision critique
qui est bon ça de la valeur parce parce
que ça il y a uniquement un cerveau
humain qui à faire ça pour l'instant
puis pour un bon bout de temps, la
créativité créativité humaine va être
difficilement reproductible puis c'est
là que ça va être game changer.
Quelqu'un qui va vraiment utiliser son
cerveau, qui va vraiment se poser pour
réfléchir à OK, c'est quoi le next move
? C'est quoi la prochaine stratégie
qu'on va faire ?
Là la valeur ajoutée va être là parce
qu'au final les choses qui
reproductibles par l'
ça reste qu' sont basic s' sont pas il
ont pas s'il y a pas eu un cerveau
humain qui a travaillé là-dessus ça va
juste reproduire un peu le average mais
tu veux pas que ton entreprise soit
average. C'est pour ça que l'importance
d'avoir un cerveau qui réfléchit aux
choses qui sont pas reproductibles par
l'
si la réponse n'est pas la dernière l'
peut le faire. Point.
Ça c'est je même si tu aimes ça, même si
tu es perfectionniste, ça peut le faire.
Fait que si tu es pas rendu au point où
c'est que tu fais des plusieurs millions
par année puis que tout roule puis tout
ça, ben fais pas une t que tu l' fais
pas une t que tu es perfectionniste. Va
optimiser tout puis après ça si tu as du
temps puis si vraiment tuour
le combinator il avait parlé du fake
work.
Puis pas le grand de YC il disait du
travail qui ressemble à de l'avancement
sans vrai sans faire bouger les
métriques qui comptent. C'est ça du fake
work.
Par exemple, écrire son site web pour la
troisème fois au lieu des ventes. Au
lieu de faire des ventes, tu vas aller
faire du ton site web. C'est sûr, c'est
pas mal plus facile, c'est pas mal plus
plaisant d'aller travailler sur ton site
web, mais c'est pas ça qui ajoute de la
de la valeur, c'est aller faire des
sales. Passer 2 he sur un email au lieu
d'en envoyer 30. optimiser son logo au
lieu de parler à des clients,
perfectionner un template que L aurait
fait en 15 en 45 secondes. Donc ça ça a
pas de leverage, c'est du fake work. En
2026, c'est du fake work. C'est pl à
dire mais c'est ça. L ne te juge pas,
elle te remet juste en face à ta
réalité. Si une outil fait ça en 30
secondes, c'est pas du travail
stratégique,
mais c'est des affaires qui sont
peut-être plus plaisantes à faire. C'est
comme une sorte de d'imaginaire, tu dis
"Ah, j'avance, j'avance, je fais ça,
c'est cool." Mais au final,
c'est pas optimiser ton temps. Tu perds
du temps à faire ça parce que N peut le
faire.
James Cars de Finite Infinite Game, il
disait donc on a on va dans une vidéo
qu'on a fait mais joueur F tu joues dans
son entreprise pour survivre la semaine
Horizon vendredi l'objectif c'est payer
des factures
va accélérer sa fin
parce qu'il va pas s'adapter lui qui est
joueur infini il va jouer sur son
entreprise pour continuer à jouer tout
au long de sa vie pour améliorer
l'entreprise pour que l'entreprise soit
dans le game. L'horizon c'est 10 ans.
L'objectif c'est construire quelque
chose qui dure dans le temps. Lia est
son meilleur outil. Fait ça va être le
meilleur outil pour continuellement
s'améliorer. Euh la question n'est pas
comment utiliser l' c'est est-ce que je
joue un jeu fini ou infini ?
Très bonne question à se poser.
Plan en 5 étapes cette semaine 1.
Cartographier lister toutes les tâches
trier. J'aime j'aime ça. Je suis
perfectionniste puis uniquement un
humain peut uniquement une humain peut
j'ai à parler uniquement un humain peut
le faire de délégalia tout ce qui n'est
pas uniquement fait par il peut être
uniquement fait par un i fais-le par un
faisle envoyer par une
je me suis mélangé non tout ce qui ne
peut pas
qui n'est pas uniquement un humain qui
peut le faire délègle à l délègle
puis commencer par une tâche puis deux
puis trois puis euh ritire pour que ce
soit optimisé puis fluide. 3 définir ta
zone genius fait ta vision relation clé
créativité stratégique c'est là que ton
toi ton temps doit aller à 80 % parce
que ça ça va faire toutes les résultats.
Fait que toi c'est quoi ton génie ?
C'est il est où ton cerveau génie ? quoi
tu peux faire toi qui a c ce levier làis
par la suite constru des systèmes chaque
fois que tu fais quelque chose pour la
deuxème fois documente et automatis moi
par exemple je parlais pour moi je suis
en train de faire moi je suis là je suis
là j'étais en train de documenter mes
mes processus j' en train de de d'avoir
la tête de ok cette tâche là j'affine
quand même une fois par semaine deux
fois par semaine ben ok ben je vais
commencer va commencer à la documenter
pour qu'elle soit vraiment fait par moi.
Mais je veux dire que moi je vais la
documenter pour qu'elle se elle se
reproduise
mais faut développer ce réflexe mental
de e attends là je fais plusieurs je le
fais quand même souvent ben on on
pourrait peut-être bien la documenter
pour potentiellement l'optimiser ben
l'optimiser l'automatiser
puis reverse engineer depuis ta vision
donc vision dans 10 an c'est où tu veux
être vision dans 3 an c'est où que tu
dois être pour être rendu à ton 10 ans.
Puis vision dans 1 an c'est où que tu
dois être pour te rendre à ton à ton 3
ans. 90 jours. Dans 90 jours, tu dois
être où pour que dans 1 an, tu sois où
tu disais. Puis les 90 prochains jours
doivent pointer dans la bonne direction.
La question de posé ce soir,
combien de mes tâches de la semaine
passée aurait pu être fait par une IO ?
Ça peut la réponse peut être extrêmement
révélatrice puis aussi choc. Tu sais
dans le sens que ça peut te surprendre
mais avec ce qu'on a vu dans la vidéo,
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de stock qui
peut être optimisé et remplacé par l'
ben automatisé par l' si la réponse
c'est plus que la moitié tu as pas un
problème d' tu as un problème de clarté
sur ton rôle. C'est quoi ton rôle en
tant qu'entrepreneur ? Il y a quelque
chose. Oh, un petit bug dans mon support
visuel. Et c'est ça la vraie opportunité
2026.
Donc de de catcher des choses que tu que
tu fais que
ça pour être fait par une
puis tu as trouvé ça utile écoute ça me
fait plaisir. Donc c'était Mathos donc
passez une excellente fin de journée.
Ciao
W. Ciao!